ap
[Musique]
c'est sur un type cas dans la danse
depuis qu'il est tout petit
son truc à lui c'est le hip hop sa mère
elle c'était la danse classique
pour lui c'est une artiste de rap et il
a terriblement peur de venir sans
glissement sauf qu'ils se trompent
veloscoot sévère
je m'installe sur paris tu t'es là pour
longtemps
juste le temps de passer le concours
d'ici là faut vraiment tout romain
boulot jabil j'ai le plaisir de vous
présenter vos nouveaux professeurs on
n'a pas de compte à rebours entre c'est
à nous de décider qui donne de quoi tout
est dans le style et a pas de règle
parce que le hip hop ça vient des tripes
j'en parle j'ai tout essayé j'ai cette
idée je leur ai montré ça marche pas si
lille comme prof
fais-toi confiance est ce que ça vous
tenterait de participer à un concours
des iep
on mixe nos styles
un hip hop airs classiques on va finir
par radio
radio avec accueil elle m'a beaucoup
parlé du elle ne m'a pas dit que vous
étiez simule un cadeau c'est le concours
pour entrer à l'école de l'opéra
j'en ai toujours aidé à rien quand avait
8 ans tu as de quoi là maintenant que tu
te rends compte qu'on peut pas gagner le
concours sur toi je me bats n'a pas fait
depuis sa fille alors qu'elle avait déjà
donné le doute a toujours été mon pire
ennemi
la peur de pas être à la hauteur
quand je te vois danser quand je danse
avec toi je vibre
même si t'es pas là
j'étais avec toi
[Musique]